[Music]
currently spider-man no way home is
running hot in theaters many will have
already seen it or will see it shortly
and of course the question arises as to
how it will continue in the future on
the one hand a new mcu trilogy around
helmhole and spider-man was announced a
few weeks ago on the other hand there
are many other options one of them is an
appearance in the animated series
spider-man into the spider-verse and
indeed tom recently expressed his
opinion about starring in the so-called
spider-verse together with co-star and
girlfriend zendaya in an interview with
sci-fi wire the two spoke of how they
would both love to appear in spider-man
across the spider-verse and are just
waiting for a call the appearance in the
animated franchise would then only be of
a vocal nature but nevertheless it would
be a logical consequence after the
multiverse has meanwhile found its way
into no way home the new mcu trilogy
will still be particularly interesting
because there is very little information
so far about what it might look like and
especially how the sony universe and the
marvel universe will be integrated
either way we recommend you watch
spiderman no way home which has been in
theaters since friday
rumors about a new mass effect series
have been circulating for a few weeks
now we already reported about the
negotiations between amazon the game
developer bioware and the parent company
electronic arts the witcher star henry
cavill has been considered for this kind
of series since the beginning of the
year at least according to the fanbase
now the 38 year old brit has addressed
the rumors himself for the very first
time in an interview with the game's
raider plus he talked about how he loved
the mass effect games and that the story
would make a fantastic film or series he
also stated that he was very interested
in talking to the people in charge in
fact there was a similar approach with
netflix the witcher series where he
brought himself up for discussion
remaining stubborn until the end and
finally got the deal for the lead role
whether that will work out the same way
again is yet to be seen for now however
we should wait for the negotiations
between amazon and electronic arts
before giving too much thought to the
casting of the individual characters
only recently avatar producer john
landau published a new set photo of
james cameron and sam worthington and
now there is some new material again
during an interview with entertainment
weekly director and creator james
cameron asked himself the question
whether it was still possible to earn
money with such an elaborate production
in fact the shooting is a very unique
challenge which is not least due to
cameron's perfectionist streak
accordingly the 67 year old is a firm
opponent of dry for wet filming which
more or less gives the impression of an
underwater shot despite the scenes being
shot in the drive instead the decision
was made to actually shoot underwater
scenes well
underwater this was often very demanding
for the participating actors for example
a 4 million litre water tank was
purchased for the filming in which the
actors occasionally had to hold their
breath for minutes during the scenes
meanwhile newcomer kate winslet amazed
the team not only with her acting skills
but above all with her underwater record
as cameron confirmed she holds the set
record with seven and a half minutes of
holding her breath
no less exciting other pictures that
were published in the course of this in
addition to behind the scenes
impressions we also get to see a concept
art of the underwater people of the mad
kyina as well as a new type of water
creature with a long neck which
apparently serves as a mound for the
navy all in all an exciting insight from
behind the scenes that definitely makes
us want to see even more avatar 2 will
be released in nearly 1 year on december
16 2022
extraction has been one of the streaming
providers hit since its netflix launch
last year in the meantime it has even
become one of the most successful
netflix movies ever which is why
attention is increasingly turning to the
sequel shooting up extraction 2 was
actually supposed to start in australia
in september but had to be moved to
prague due to several restrictions a
first impression was given on social
media related actor chris hemsworth and
director sam hargrave spoke in good
spirits from a movie train hemsworth not
only announces the start of filming in
this snowy czech republic but also the
fact that his character tyler rake is
still among the living so it is already
clear that we can expect to see a few
changes in the sequel at least the team
behind and in front of the camera seems
to remain the same the russo brothers
who also produced avengers end game are
still mainly in charge the script is
also once again the work of joe russo as
already mentioned we will also see the
main character tyler rake again although
the background officer post demise must
first be clarified after the end of the
first part according to the us magazine
collider extraction 2 is just the
beginning of something much bigger rumor
has it that an entire movie universe is
being created under the direction of
russo's company agbo but for now we're
looking forward to extraction 2 which
will probably celebrate its premiere at
the end of the next year at the earliest
is new animation news from disney as the
company announced on instagram a movie
called strange world is currently in
production disney itself calls it a
journey deep into an uncharted and
treacherous land where fantastical
creatures await more specifically it
will be about a family of explorers
known as clade who are on a quest
through the vast expanse of space to
discover new life similar to raya and
the last dragon the movie is supposed to
be family friendly and humorous but also
dark and serious at times incidentally
behind strange world is none other than
raya and the last dragon creator don
hall who also made the oscar winning
baymax and the animated classic tarzan
screenwriter queen again who likewise
contributed to raya and the last dragon
is also back on board not much more is
known at this point but there is still
some time until the release on november
23rd 2022 anyway
after a long period of silence progress
is being made in the kingsman franchise
with kingsman 3 the film series starring
taran eggerton is to be shot next year
in an interview with comicbook.com
director matthew vaughn revealed that
cameras will start rolling in september
2022 so far it looks like kingsman 3
will be the final installment in the
movie series powering any possible
spin-offs or prequels like the kingsman
the beginning it will be interesting to
see how this story will carry on after
the last spin off kingsman the golden
circle but sadly vonn left us completely
in the dark both in this regard and in
terms of a potential release date as
soon there is new information on this we
will of course let you
know the big reunion of the harry potter
actors on january 1st 2021 on the
occasion of the 20th anniversary of the
sorcerer's stone is approaching in
keeping with the christmas season a few
days ago there was a new poster to
admire which shows the actress in
hogwarts great hall this is a nice
addition to the image published last
week which showed only the main actor
trio pictured here alongside daniel
radcliffe emma watson rupert grint from
left to right are the actors of fred and
george weasley draco malfoy luna
lovegood dean thomas neville longbottom
and ginny weasley we are definitely
looking forward to the reunion and are
eagerly anticipating january 1st 2022
when harry potter returned to hogwarts
will be shown on hbo max
[Music]
well this is all the news we have for
you this week if you like this video
please leave a like and subscribe to us
so you don't miss anything and be sure
to check out the new trailer for
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore as well as the second trailer
for the banana lovers namely
minions the rise of grow
[Music]